Here's another perspective.
And it has to do with probability distributions.
Now remember a probability distribution is a function.
of its random variable
we talked about this in previous videos, right?
The random variable when you plot it.
Will produce a probability distribution a graph?
And graphs can be represented or expressed
as functions so equations.
A probability distribution. Let me say this again a probability distribution.
Can be expressed in two ways
as a mathematical equation.
or as a graph
so
we have probability distributions and we can
illustrate a probability distribution using
it's equation.
My point here is
how
multiplication can combine
To probability distributions and merge them
into one.
and
by multiplying two functions you produce
a new
graph, that is the
well the product of two other graphs.
So suppose we have f of x in G of x.
f of x
is a function of x squared and
G of X is a function of X cubed.
now if we multiply
x squared with X cubed
the power rule tells us that you would add up.
The powers so we would get 2 plus 3, which is 5 so this
is what the function would look like.
the purple line
that is the same thing as well multiplying these
two functions.
So fine remove these again.
The I function represented by the purple graph.
This is what happens if you were to.
multiply
x squared
and X cubed
and you get the same effect by multiplying the functions.
So you can see the green and the purple.
Are identical functions?
this is simple obviously, but
it is important to keep this in mind.
Especially when we look at examples where
we have.
What where we are going to deal with the Bayesian theorem?
but we have
a multiple events
multiple events that would give us
the posterior